all right let's go to five headlines
[Music]
and we're about to run through a bunch
of headlines remember you know there's
there's so much going on in the world
and so much to keep track of
uh you got to get a reader's pass at
dailywire.com that's going to keep you
up to date on all the stories and news
and everything
i get a reader's pass today from
dailywire.com to get exclusive op-eds
from
me and from the other podcast hosts as
well as guest writers in-depth analysis
from our daily wire reporters on top of
our regular breaking news
this membership tier is already a
bargain at three bucks a month but if
you join today you're gonna get your
first month for 99 cents you get access
to our mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news
special content as well as um the
community of daily wire members who are
actively commenting and discussing our
content so again dailywire.com
subscribe here's a good place to start
nice transition two women have been
arrested for assaulting
a democratic state senator in wisconsin
they went to the protest
i think it was in milwaukee the senator
was there taking pictures
this is a democrat and they run up and
assault him
for no reason they just assaulted him
here are the mugshots of these lovely
ladies you can take a look there
samantha r hamer and karita e o'reilly
now here comes the twist ending one of
these women
is a teacher can you guess which one
if you guess the green haired one well
nice guess and i wish you were right
because that would be just perfect
for what we're talking about but no
actually the blonde chick is the teacher
um but either way not just a teacher
okay
she's a a school social worker who
specializes in working with kids with
emotional needs and behavioral issues
this is someone who's supposed to be
helping children
with emotional needs and behavioral
issues who is out in the street
assaulting state senators
number two let's um let's stay here on
the subject of lovely ladies at blm
protests here's a portland mom
offering a rather loud and unsolicited
explanation as to why
she is out protesting watch this
i'm so tired of it i am so
tired i'm sleep deprived because i'm a
single mom
and i work full time and i have to come
and spend my nights with you
because i can't stand in my own streets
and say black lives matter
black lives matter that's why we're here
we're not here because of some
building we don't care about the
building we don't care about your stupid
fence
we care about black lives
and i'm a mom and i heard george when he
called out
mama that's why i'm here
that's why i'm here because george
called out for his mama
you all have moms your child loves you
george's mom loved you and my kids love
me and i want to go
home to them but they agree that this is
important
and it's not about some white ladies
it's not about me it's about black lives
matter
there are so many amazing black women
have been doing this
fight for years and i showed up late i'm
so tardy to this party
but i'm making up for because i'm so
angry
so angry and black black people are
allowed to be angry and
who cares that somebody graffiti's on
this stupid building we're talking about
human lives
of course none of what she's saying
there makes any sense whatsoever
it was a stirring monologue i'll give
her that very well rehearsed
um and so i give her credit for that but
she says she can't stand in the street
and shout black lives matter
meanwhile that's exactly what she's
doing
she's she's standing in the street
shouting about how she can't shout
i can't shout black lives matter i'm not
allowed to do what i'm doing right now
this is outrageous i can't do the thing
that i'm doing
um and you know in fact not only can you
stand in the street and shot black lives
matter but
in many cases you can commit felonies
and as long as you shout black lives
matter while you do it
you're not gonna be arrested so this is
another protester who just
has imagined a form of oppression in her
head she has fabricated it like science
fiction
just make believe and she's out
protesting against
the oppression that she made up in her
head
and the whole bit about you know george
floyd crying out for his mama and she's
there for george
uh you know i'm sorry call me cynical i
i just don't buy the performative tears
for george floyd at this
point i i don't buy it i'm sorry i two
months later and and you're still
overcome with grief
in tears no there's quite a lot of
death and murder in the streets of
portland or any other city every day
has this woman cried tears for them i
mean you you're apparently so
empathetic that this one person you
don't know dies
two months later you're still not over i
mean two months later you're still in
tears literally breaking down weeping in
the street
well so with all of that overwhelming
exuding empathy do you what about all
the other death is it
does that i mean do you walk through
your day every day
just overcome with tears at death and
murder or is it just this one particular
death that upsets you so much and not
all the others
we talked about brittany hill yesterday
young mother gunned down by chicago gang
members while holding her one-year-old
daughter
her daughter cried out for mama what
about that
why isn't this woman breaking down
publicly in tears over that
i mean is it because her tears
um only come out
in politically and ideologically
expedient moments is that why
number three here's some good news okay
let's too much bad news let's get to
some good news
all of that chronovirus cash was handed
out you know loans and stimuluses from
the government
and if you're wondering whatever
happened to that don't worry it was put
to good use
david t hines of miami obtained nearly 4
million in loans
and went out and bought a lamborghini
there's a
the car right there not a bad not a bad
vehicle
um not as nice as what i drive you know
i mean it's a little bit it's a few
steps down
for my tastes anyway but here's here's
clickorlando.com
reporting says a south florida man
fraudulently obtained 3.9 million
dollars in federal chronovirus relief
loans
using money uh some of the money to buy
a 318 thousand dollar lamborghini
prosecutors say david d hines was
arrested in charge last week with bank
fraud making false statements to
financial institutions and engaging in
transactions
defense attorney chad uh petrowski
said heinz is a legitimate business
owner who is anxious to tell
his side of the story he's he's got his
side of the
it's not what it looks like all right
like i know
it looks bad right now i've got a 319
000 car
that i bought with chronovirus loans i
know it looks bad i know how this looks
got a good explanation i'm uh i'm i'm
anxious to hear what it is i
we we're not provided the explanation
but now it's kind of a cliffhanger we'll
have to check back i guess i'll keep
updating us on this story
uh let's go to the ap joe biden
yesterday was photographed holding
his notes um for remarks he was given
and he was giving remarks and he had
notes
and the ap got a good a good view of his
notes
let's look at this picture there
um okay his his handwriting is almost
worse than mine
and my eyesight isn't very good so let
me see if i can um
okay it says camilla harris do not hold
the grudges
is that so is he is he
listing good things about her um
campaigned with me and jill
talent does that say talented
talented i can't tell what that says
hold on
talented great help to
campaign great respect for her how does
he
re i have this problem with my own notes
when i write notes for myself and i
i can't tell it's like a foreign
language i can't read my own handwriting
i go back and try to
i have to decipher it i have to call in
you know like an egyptian
egyptologist are they the ones that
decipher hieroglyphics anyway
um uh i'm just trying to figure out so
he's he's listing good things about or
is he saying
camila harris do not hold like he's
telling himself not to hold grudges
against her
are these these are reminders to himself
about what he should think about her is
that what this is
it's remind you ever seen that movie
memento with um
you know where the main character has uh
he he's a he has no memory so he forgets
things after
40 seconds he has to he has to write all
these notes he actually tattoos them on
himself
just to tell him what he should be
thinking and feeling kind of reminds me
of that
all right number five finally very
important report here in the daily mail
listen to this it says
women across the country are reporting a
rise in
aggressive eye contact since the
introduction of face coverings in some
public places
new laws introduced over the weekend
force customers to wear face masks and
all shop stations banks and post offices
while it was also mandatory
to wear coverings on public transport
but many women have been sharing stories
online of aggressive eye contact
and quote hard staring from men wearing
masks
with one tweeting grown men staring at
you with a mask on is worse than when
they don't have a mask
un women uk executive director claire
burnett uh or barnett
told female that's with
f-e-m-a-i-l uh it said
as we work to build back better
following lockdowns we need to prevent
the lack of witness of
anti-social behavior due to less
populated public spaces
as well as the anonymity face coverings
can provide leading to further rises in
harassment and threatening actions
towards women girls and minoritized
groups
this will require widespread changes in
attitudes behaviors
uh creating an understanding that
behavior like unwanted and persistent
staring is intimidating that we will
have a role to play in making our public
spaces
more inclusive okay so this is someone
from the u.n
[Music]
who is set on the task of dealing with
the problem of aggressive eye contact i
i don't even what is a how can you make
eye contact aggressively
hard staring i don't even know what that
is
but either way this once again we have
the feminists
strong independent women who are
traumatized
by aggressive eye contact
sure that's feminism for you
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content